COLUMBIA BUT ALSO BE SMUGGLED TO
PARTS OF LATIN AMERICA BY BOAT.
JOINING ME NOW IS BRANDON JUDD.
BRANDON, I MEAN, AS LONG AS THEY
KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
FOR THE MOST PART STAY, IS THERE
ANY END IN THIS TRAIL OF
MIGRANTS THAT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO OVERWHELM OUR
SYSTEM?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
UNTIL WE GET BACK TO A POSITION
OF STRENGTH LIKE WE WERE IN THE
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE'RE
GOING TRUMP, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS BLOOD AND
IT IS NOT FLOOD.
IT IS ACIT NOW ME.
IT IS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THE SYNONYMOUS OF PEOPLE COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE POLICIES OF TRUMP IN ORDER
TO GET THIS UNDER CONTROL BUT IF
WE DON'T, THE CATCH AND RELEASE
IS GOING TO CONTINUE AND PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO COME.
IN DEL RIO ALONE, SINCE THE
HAITIANS WERE UNDERNEATH THE
RICH, WE HAVE CAUGHT PEOPLE FROM
GAMBIA.
SENEGAL AND ANGOLA, THAT IS IN
WESTERN AFRICA.
AND WE GOT PEOPLE FROM BRAZIL,
COLOMBIA, VENEZUELA, CHILE, FROM
SOUTH AMERICA AND OF COURSE, THE
CENTRAL AMERICANS, NICARAGUA, EL
SALVADOR, HONDURAS, GUATEMALA.
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE GLOBE TO CONTINUE TO
COME BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT JOE
BIDEN IS GOING TO RELEASE THEM
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THEM TO
STOP.
>> Laura: BRANDON, DO YOU
AGREE THAT THE BIG SHOW, WE ARE
GOING TO SEND SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE AND THERE WERE NOT VERY
MANY.
MAYBE 2,000 OUT OF THE 15 OR SO
THOUSAND.
BUT THAT THAT WAS JUST KIND OF A
BONE THEY HAD TO THROW TO PRO
ENFORCEMENT, YOU KNOW,
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD DEMOCRATS OUT
THERE THAT SEEMS LIKE A DROP IN
THE BUCKET, IS IT NOT?
>> OH, IT IS.
IT IS THE ELECTION.
IT IS WHAT THEY DO.
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION TO TRY TO
SHOW THAT WE ARE IN FACT DOING
SOMETHING IN REALITY, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF UPWARDS OF 60 TO 70%
OF THE PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY WILL ULTIMATELY BE
RELEASED INTO NINE STATES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
TOP OF THIS TSUNAMI WILL
CONTINUE UNTIL THE PUBLIC STANDS
OUT AND SAYS HE HAS GOT TO STOP.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE WANTING ABOUT
THE BORDER AGENTS ON HORSEBACK,
AT WHAT THEY HAVE HAD TROUBLE IF
THEY WERE AGENTS ON HORSEBACK'S
WORK POLICE OFFICERS ON
HORSEBACK ON JANUARY 6th?
WHAT THEY HAVE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
>> NO, THEY WOULD HAVE UPLOADED
IT, OF COURSE.
WHAT A GREAT JOB THEY WERE
DOING.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE
DONE.
>> Laura: THROWING DEMENTED
OFFICERS UNDER THE BUS.
MAYORKAS WASN'T SO BAD ON THIS.
HE HAD THE GALL STATUS.
WATCH.
>> CAN THAT BORDER PATROL COUNT
ON YOU AND PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
COME TO A DETERMINATION BASED ON
THE FACTS AND NOT BASED ON
TWITTER OUTREACH?
>> THEY SURE CAN.
THEY ARE HEROIC, WHAT THEY DO.
I'M INCREDIBLY PROUD TO WORK
ALONGSIDE THEM.
>> Laura: BRANDON DO YOUR
AGENTS BELIEVE THAT?
>> WE ARE PRORATED.
HE DOES NOT BELIEVE IT.
THAT IS WHY HE MADE THOSE
COMMENTS.
THERE'S NO RATES THIS DISCUSSION
IS GOING TO BE FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL WENT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYS OF THOSE AGENTS WILL PAY.
THEY WILL HAVE TO COME UP WITH
SOME THING.
INVEST PATIENTS ARE NEVER
IMPARTIAL WHEN YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATE